judaism
christianity and islam are typically
grouped together
under the same umbrella of abrahamic
religion
this video is going to show that far
from being a religion in the
monotheistic lineage of
abraham christianity in fact has its
origin in pagan cults
christianity has the doctrine of the
trinity in which god
is said to manifest as three persons the
father
son and holy spirit let's compare this
concept
of three related divinities to different
pagan religions
the ancient egyptians had the trinity of
our moon
ray antar an egyptian hymn reads
all gods are three our moon ray antar
babylonians worship the trinity of nana
shamash and ishtar
hinduism has the concept of trimurti
in which the supreme god brahman is said
to manifest as the three forms
brahma vishnu and shiva the hindu text
padma purana states he who is the
eternal god
became the three gods brahma vishnu and
shiva
the greeks had the goddess hekate whom
they described as
triple headed and goddess of the triple
ways
the romans venerated diana as diva
triformis
which means three formed a roman poet
wrote
all three formed goddess to thee i
dedicate the pine tree
northwestern european tribes worshiped a
group of three female deities
known as matrone which means matrons
[Music]
persians had the triad ahura mazda
mithra
and anahita an ancient royal inscription
reads
may ahura mazda anahita and mithra
protect me and my building against evil
we can see that this concept of three
related divinities
is an ancient phenomenon which has been
present in different pagan religions
throughout the world it's important to
point out
that the christian trinity differs in
its finer details when compared to these
other cults
however this basic concept of three
related divinities
is common to all of them and is
fundamentally pagan
the greek philosopher aristotle had this
to say
about the mystical significance of the
number three
just as the pythagoreans say the whole
and all things are delimited by the
three
for end middle and beginning have the
number of the whole
which is that of the triad wherefore we
use this number
also in the worship of the gods taking
it from nature
as a law of it
in christianity jesus is the incarnate
son of god
who is said to possess two natures one
divine
and one human this idea of a god man
hybrid
is fundamentally pagan greco-roman
religions
were filled with tales of gods
procreating with human women
and begetting god men for example the
chief god in the greek pantheon
zeus visited the human woman danae
in the form of golden reign and fathered
perseus
a god-man hercules also the son of zeus
is another example of a god-man the new
testament states
that the role of the incarnate son of
god is to be the savior of mankind
the father has sent his son to be the
savior of the world
the belief that gods became incarnate as
men
and acted as universal saviors was also
common in paganism perhaps the best
known example
is the roman dictator julius caesar
an ancient inscription has this to say
about him
descendant of aries and aphrodite the
god who has become manifest
and universal savior of human life here
julius caesar is said to be a
manifestation of the gods
and the savior of mankind another direct
parallel can be found in the gospel of
mark
the beginning of the good news about
jesus the messiah
the son of god this statement that jesus
the son of god
is the beginning of the good news is
also mirrored by another roman dictator
augustus
the birthday of the god has been for the
whole world the beginning of good news
concerning him the concept of a human
being
who is a divine son of god the savior of
mankind
and good news was a sort of template
that was applied to people of great
power and authority
we've seen that the history of paganism
is littered with such examples
and the christian conception of jesus
was just another incarnate god
in a long line of incarnate gods that
had preceded him
the early christian apologist justin
martyr considered a saint in the
catholic church
admitted that christianity had borrowed
its concept of divine sonship from
pagans
when we say that the word jesus christ
the firstborn of god
was produced without sexual union and
that he was crucified
and died and rose again and ascended to
heaven
we propound nothing new or different
from what you pagans believe
regarding those whom you consider sons
of jupiter
the gospel of matthew states that jesus
foretold he would die
and rise again after a period of three
days and three nights
for as jonah was three days and three
nights in the belly of a huge fish
saw the son of man will be three days
and three nights in the heart of the
earth
very early on churches taught that
during his three-day
and three-night absence jesus descended
into hell
the apostles creed is an early statement
of christian belief
it states i believe in jesus christ
his only son our lord was crucified
died and was buried he descended into
hell
the third day he arose again from the
dead
these beliefs mirror an ancient sumerian
myth
about the goddess inanna which states
from the great heaven inanna set her
mind on the great below
inanna abandoned heaven abandoned earth
and ascended to the underworld
after three days and three nights had
passed thusla inanna arise the gospel of
matthew
also tells us that something
extraordinary happened when jesus died
at that moment the curtain of the temple
was torn in two
from top to bottom the earth shook the
rocks split
and the tombs broke open the bodies of
many holy people who had died
were raised to life they came out of the
tombs
after jesus's resurrection and went into
the holy city and appeared to many
people
now none of the other gospels mention
this astonishing
incident of the walking dead only
matthew reports it
let's compare the accounts of matthew
and mark regarding the death of jesus
notice that even though mark's account
is virtually identical to that of
matthew
mark does not mention the rising of the
dead saints
if such a miraculous event really
happened then there will be no
rational reason for mark to omit it from
his gospel
consider that the apostle paul had the
perfect opportunity
to mention this story when he was
preaching to an audience that was
skeptical about life after death
but if it is preached that christ has
been raised from the dead
how can some of you say that there is no
resurrection of the dead
paul could have easily proven that there
is life after death
by mentioning the numerous resurrections
that took place when the dead saints
walked the streets of jerusalem
he did not mention anything about such
an event because it never happened
flavius josephus was a first century
historian who was born in jerusalem
even though he was a prolific writer and
documented much about the city
he also failed to mention anything about
this most public of miracles
even conservative christian scholarship
rejects the historicity of this event
the new testament scholar mike lacona
stated that this story is a strange
report
and literary special effects the
theologian
william lane craig stated that probably
only a few
conservative scholars would treat the
story as historical
if matthew's story of the walking dead
is an invention
then from where did he get his
inspiration for such a tale
it just happens to be present among
pagan cultures
the ancient greeks celebrated a
three-day festival
known as anthesteria during which it was
believed
that the dead came back to life and
walked among the living in the cities
the roman poet virgil wrote that when
julius caesar was assassinated
phantoms of an earthly power were seen
in the falling darkness
the gospel of john narrates to us the
following conversation between jesus and
his disciples
this bread is my flesh which i will give
for the life of the world
whoever eats my flesh and drinks my
blood has eternal life
and i will raise them up at the last day
for my flesh is real food and my blood
is real drink
whoever eats my flesh and drinks my
blood remains in me
and i in them here jesus instituted the
ritualistic consumption of bread and
wine
said to represent his flesh and blood
note the great importance that is placed
on the ritual
it was claimed to bestow eternal life
all of this has precedent
in the ancient egyptian cult of osiris
osiris was believed to be the god of the
dead and the god of resurrection
the body of osiris was represented by
bread the valley gives you bread from
the burial of her father osiris
your loaves are osiris the blood of
osiris was represented by wine
my blood is drunk even my redness you
are wine you are not wine
but the guts of osiris the ritualistic
consumption
of osiris in the form of bread and wine
was believed to allow one to partake in
the nature of osiris and be granted life
your eyes are opened by the earth your
limbs are gathered
raise yourself up when the great bread
and this wine like water
were given to him the bread and wine
ritual is performed in churches to the
present day
as a way of commemorating jesus
resurrection back to life
in christianity the symbol of the
resurrection is the cross
most christians assume that its design
is based on the t-shaped roman torture
instrument
however the bible itself does not
precisely describe
the shape of the cross it merely states
it was made of wood
or timber you may be wondering where its
design
originated from like the bread and wine
eating ritual
the cross also happens to have a
parallel in ancient egyptian religion
compare the christian cross to the
egyptian ankh
their resemblance is not just in shape
but also in meaning
as egyptian hieroglyphics use the symbol
to represent the word for life
here the egyptian god horus is bringing
a dead pharaoh back to life using the
ankh
we can see that the ankh and christian
cross are both linked to resurrection
the early christian historian socrates
scholasticus
recorded a fascinating argument between
christians and egyptian pagans
who both laid claim to the cross when
the temple of serapis was torn down
and laid bare they were found in it
engraven on stones
certain characters which they call
hieroglyphics having the forms of
crosses
both the christians and pagans on seeing
them
appropriated and applied them to their
respective religions
for the christians claimed this
character as peculiarly
theirs but the pagans allege that it
might a pertain
to christ and serapis in common
[Music]
just how did the original message of
jesus transform
from the pure monotheism of the old
testament into the paganistic
religion of christianity today did early
christians get together
and agree upon a secret agenda to
corrupt the religion
and the masses just went along with it
there is no need to resort to conspiracy
theories to understand what actually
happened
when there are multiple ideologies in a
geographic area
you often find that there is an exchange
of ideas
with the dominant ideology prevailing in
the exchange this is known as syncretism
the people who allow changes to creep
into a religion are not necessarily
doing it with an evil intention
it may come about due to pressure from
society or ruling authorities
it may even seem natural to adopt
certain beliefs and practices
if culturally that is what a people are
used to
historically this is what happened with
christianity
jewish people were the initial target
audience of the evangelism of jesus and
his disciples
however they largely rejected jesus as
the messiah
jesus only gained a sizable following
after he ascended to heaven
when the apostle paul started
evangelizing to gentiles
i.e non-jews paul preached a modified
version
of the message of jesus that was
stripped of its jewish elements
such as circumcision and keeping the
sabbath this watered-down version
appealed to gentiles who started to
embrace paul's teachings in large
numbers
culminating in the pagan roman empire
adopting christianity
as its official state religion several
centuries after jesus
so we need to understand the mindset of
the gentiles
who first received paul's message in
order to understand how paganism crept
into christianity
when jewish people heard stories about
jesus performing amazing miracles
they would have understood him in the
same context as the likes of moses
and the other israelite prophets who
were all granted signs and wonders by
god
however such stories about jesus would
have been interpreted very differently
by pagan gentiles this is illustrated in
the new testament book of acts which
informs us
in lystra they sat a man who was lame he
had been that way from birth
and had never walked paul looked
directly at him
saw that he had faith to be healed and
called out stand up on your feet
at that the man jumped up and began to
walk when the crowd
saw what paul had done they shouted in
the lyconian language
that gods have come down to us in human
form
we can see that the pagan gentile
peoples to whom paul was preaching
were in the habit of idolizing human
beings
with this in mind it's easy to
appreciate why gentiles from a pagan
background
would idolize jesus upon hearing stories
about the miracles of jesus they would
naturally interpret him
in the same light as the greco-roman
gods they were used to
the early church emerged in both a
jewish and gentile world
and so christians had to reconcile the
pure monotheism they had inherited from
judaism
with the polytheism they are derived
from paganism gregory of nissa
is a 4th century bishop who is venerated
as a saint
in the roman catholic and eastern
orthodox churches
he wrote for the truth passes in the
mean between
these two conceptions destroying each
heresy
and yet accepting what is useful to it
from each
the jewish dogma is destroyed by the
acceptance of the word
and by belief in the spirit while the
polytheistic
era of the greek school is made to
vanish by the unity of the nature
abrogating this imagination
of plurality here gregory of nisa
acknowledged that the christian
conception of god
is neither purely the polytheism of the
greeks nor purely the monotheism of the
jews but rather a mixture of both
the quran declares that those christians
who deify jesus are imitating pagans of
old
here the quran demonstrates remarkable
insight by pointing out
that christian beliefs about jesus
originate from past pagan religions
the message of islam like christianity
was also delivered to a pagan audience
but unlike christianity islam's
monotheism was
untainted and remains pure to this day
even rabbis acknowledge this fact
because they permit jewish people
to pray in muslim places of worship in a
situation where no synagogue is
available
rabbi maimonides a leading authority in
jewish law
wrote the following with regards to the
islamic concept of god
these ishmaelites are not idol
worshippers in the least
and paganism has long since cut off from
their mouths and their hearts
and they worship the singular god
properly and without any blemish
by comparison jewish people are
forbidden from even setting foot
inside churches rabbi maimonides had
this to say about christianity
know that this christian nation with all
their many different sects
are all idol worshipers and all their
holidays are forbidden
and we deal with them regarding
religious issues as we would pagans
the kaaba is situated in saudi arabia
and represents the holiest site on earth
for muslims
today it contains neither idols nor
images
but before the advent of islam the pagan
arabs
housed numerous idols inside the kaaba
so central was the kaaba to idolatry
that pagans from all over arabia would
make pilgrimage there
in the short span of just 23 years
islam managed to completely eliminate
all traces of idolatry
taking people away from their worship of
carved images
to the worship of the one true god of
abraham when it comes to preserving the
purity of monotheism
just how did islam succeed where
christianity failed
the quran takes into account the
psychology of its audience
which is demonstrated in its use of
language when god defines the
relationship between himself
and mankind he avoids terms like father
when referring to himself and sons of
god when referring to human beings
such language can be easily
misunderstood especially in the minds of
those who come from a background of
idolatry
and are used to interpreting such
language literally the quran also
outlines its doctrines clearly with god
describing his nature in such a way that
it is impossible to get it confused
with polytheism
[Music]
god revealed the quran in order to
rescue mankind
from the polytheism that we are drowning
in the quran
restores the original monotheistic
message of jesus
who is not part of a trinity but rather
a human messenger
and the messiah
[Music]
foreign
to learn more about the true message of
jesus please download your free copy of
the book
jesus man messenger messiah from the
link below